67%
of developers pick Claude Code in a
blind code quality test and 65% prefer
using Code X day-to-day. That
contradiction tells you everything about
where we are in May 2026.
This isn't which tool is better, that
question is dead. The developers
shipping the fastest right now aren't
picking a side, they're running both.
And the ones still arguing about it on
Reddit, they are hitting rate limits
while the dual tool crowd is already on
their next commit. By the end of this
video, you'll know exactly where each
tool wins, where each one falls apart,
and how the smartest developers route
work between them.
Here's the core difference that every
comparison buries under benchmark
tables. Claude Code is a pair
programmer. It sits next to you, reads
your code base, adapts to your style,
asks questions when things are unclear,
is interactive, is opinionated. It will
absolutely try to refactor [music] your
entire auth module when you ask it to
fix typo. Code X is an autonomous
contractor. You hand it a spec, it goes
away, comes back with a pull request, is
more deliberate. It reads more context
[music] before acting. It does exactly
what you asked, sometimes frustratingly
exactly. The community nailed this
distinction better than any blog post.
One developer put it this way, "Claude
is more willing to sin by overreaching.
Code X is more willing to sin by under
reaching." 1400 upvotes because every
developer who's used both went, "Yeah,
that's exactly right."
>> [music]
>> In practice, Claude Code gives you 26
life cycle hooks, hierarchical project
memory files, skills, plugins, sub
agents, and the kind of configurability
that makes a senior engineers eyes light
up. Codex gives you a rust binary that
starts fast, runs in a kernel level
sandbox, and just works out of the box.
Claude optimizes for the developer who
wants control. [music] Codex optimizes
for the developer who wants throughput.
Neither approach is wrong, but they're
very, very different.
The data here is clear. Front-end and UI
work, Claude code wins. Not close.
Whether it's React, Next JS, [music]
Tailwind, or Figma to code, Claude
consistently produces better layouts,
catches more edge cases, and understands
design intent in a way Codex simply
doesn't. In a head-to-head Figma
conversion test, Claude preserved the
layout, exported images correctly, and
caught a race condition. Codex made a
different looking page and missed the
bug. The community consensus is blunt.
One Codex user admitted, "The only thing
Claude wins is UI, hands down."
>> [music]
>> Another said, "Codex makes, and I quote,
shitty UIs no matter how many skills
[music] I put in. DevOps and terminal
work, Codex wins. Also not close." GPT
5.5 scores 82.7%
on Terminal Bench 2.0. [music]
Claude's Opus 4.7 scores 69.4.
That's a 13-point gap, the largest
single benchmark gap between these tools
in all of 2026.
Bash scripts, CI/CD pipelines,
infrastructure automation, Docker, and
Kubernetes scaffolding, Codex just
handles it.
Back-end and business logic, this is the
contested zone. Benchmarks put them
within a few points of each other.
Claude writes more documentation and
structure. Codex ships shorter, tighter
code. Pick based on your style, not on
capability. Both are excellent here.
Full stack developers are increasingly
splitting their work by layer. Claude
handles the front end,
>> [music]
>> Codex handles the back end. Not as a
theoretical framework, as their Monday
through Friday workflow. Now for the
part most comparison videos miss. Most
of the time when developers complain
that Claude got dumber or Codex is worse
this week, the model didn't change at
all. The harness did. The harness is the
software wrapper around the language
model. The agent loop, the tools, the
context management, the rate limiting,
and in the last 90 days both tools
proved this the hard way. On Anthropic's
side, a bug shipped March 26th cleared
the model's thinking after an hour of
idle time, making Claude seem forgetful
and repetitive. [music]
A separate update killed prompt cache
hits, dropping from 97% to single
digits. Then rate limit consumption
spiked up to 50 times faster than
normal. Same model weights, dramatically
different output quality. Anthropic
published a full postmortem on April
24th confirming all three bugs were in
the harness, not the model.
Scale AI's research drives this point
home even harder. When you run the same
model through a standardized test
scaffold versus an optimized agent
system, scores vary by 10 to 22 points.
Same brain, different spinal cord,
wildly different results. So the next
time you see a head-to-head comparison
online, ask one question. Which layer
are they measuring? Because most debates
about models are really debates about
harnesses dressed up in fancier clothes.
Now to what matters to working
developers. Not benchmarks, not
architecture diagrams, the day-to-day.
Usage limits are the number one pain
point driving switching behavior right
now. It's not even close. Claude Code's
Pro plan at $20 a month, developers
report hitting the wall after 20 minutes
of Opus usage. [music] The Max plan at
$100 or $200, it drains fast. Multiple
posts with thousands of upvotes showing
screenshots of limits hit on trivial
tasks. Meanwhile, Codex users on ChatGPT
Plus at $20 keep saying the same thing.
I can use it all day and never hit the
limit. That's the single biggest reason
people are switching. Underneath the
limit sits the token efficiency problem.
Claude Code consumes roughly three to
four times more tokens per task than
Codex for similar quality output. In a
direct comparison,
>> [music]
>> Claude burned 6.2 million tokens on an
Express JS refactor. Codex used 1.5
million. Claude finished faster in wall
clock time, but the token bill, that's
where it hurts. Then there's the trust
issue. Anthropic had a brutal March and
April. A 59 megabyte source code leak
from a botched NPM package. Two months
of harness regressions they didn't
publicly acknowledge until April 24th.
And on April 22nd, they AB tested
removing Claude Code from the $20 Pro
plan. Reddit exploded. [music]
They reverted within hours, but the
damage was done. OpenAI's Codex lead
pounced immediately. Tweeted that Codex
will continue to be available on both
free and $20 plans. Quote, "Transparency
and trust are two principles we will not
break." Bold statement from the company
that just doubled their per token
pricing with GPT 5.5. But the PR worked.
Codex isn't spotless either. Credit
drain reports, limits tightening without
notice, and GPT-5.5 scored 86% on the AA
Omniscience hallucination eval. Speed
and terminal dominance come with a
hallucination tax. Community sentiment
as of today, deeply split. Not along
brand loyalty lines, but along workflow
preference. Senior engineers on large
code bases lean Claude. Solo developers
and small teams lean Codex. Price
sensitive developers lean Codex [music]
hard. Enterprise users who don't see the
bill lean Claude. And a growing third
camp just uses both and lets the tools
argue with each other.
Which brings us [music] to the answer.
The use both workflow has gone from a
fringe experiment to the consensus power
user setup in about 90 days. The proof
isn't a Reddit opinion. OpenAI shipped
an official plugin that runs inside
[music] Anthropic's Claude code. Let me
say that again. OpenAI built a plugin
for their competitor's product. It
exposes slash commands so you can have
Codex review code that Claude just
wrote, all in one terminal. Their
announcement, "We want people to be able
to use Codex wherever they like. That
means in Claude code." The logic is that
simple. Self-review by the same model
that wrote the code has a fundamental
ceiling. It's like proofreading an email
you just sent. Your brain fills in what
should be there instead of what is.
Using a different model to review
catches a different class of bugs
entirely. The workflow's getting real
adoption. [music]
Claude plans and writes, Codex reviews.
Claude handles front end, Codex handles
back end. Running parallel attempts on
hard problems and picking the better
result. Mitchell Hashimoto, the guy
behind Terraform, runs separate
checkouts with different agents on the
same task and picks the winner. Calls
himself the mayor, managing two [music]
agents. The economics work, $20 for
Claude Pro, $20 for ChatGPT Plus, $40
total. When you hit Claude's limit, you
switch to Codex. When you want deeper
reasoning, you switch back. For many
developers, that $40 dual plan
outperforms a $100 max subscription
because you never fully stall, you just
rotate. Here's where we land.
>> [music]
>> The model quality crown belongs to
Claude. Opus 4.7 leads SWE bench, cursor
bench, and multi-tool orchestration
benchmarks. The terminal and devops
crown belongs to Codex. GPT 5.5 leads by
13 points, and that gap [music] is
consistent across every independent
reviewer. The product trust crown, up
for grabs. And that matters because the
best model in the world doesn't help you
if you hit the rate limit mid-refactor
or if a harness bug eats your afternoon.
The question that matters in May 2026 is
not Claude code or Codex, it's what's
your routing logic between them. Both
tools now read each other's config
files, share open standards for memory
and plugins, and have exactly one real
lock-in point, your subscription. Cancel
one, you only lose that one. Figure out
your routing logic, that's the edge
right now.